let me jump to the story
this is a story from newsweek and it
helps us understand why it is that uh we
end up with the politicians we end up
with
jennifer lawrence admits to having
nightmares about tucker carlson supposed
to date him okay yeah right she
she's she's just mad
yeah her interview
this was uh oh that people want to date
her yeah you're just upset because you
on a date look
in vogue's october issue
she said that she has recurring
nightmares she says i can't eff with
people who aren't political anymore you
live in the united states of america you
you have to be political it's too dire
politics are killing people
she said that she has nightmares
starring tucker carlson huh okay
these people they're they're they're out
of their minds yeah you know we talked
about you know wild boars guns these are
people who've probably never stepped
foot in a wooded area
they've probably never driven outside of
a you know an incorporated town or
whatever been attacked by a raccoon
lately what was the old saying first
world issues yes yeah yeah yeah yeah so
my life is so good let's just google
jennifer lawrence net worth oh yeah what
is it what is that net worth
did you get it billions and millions i'm
sure of course it is jennifer lawrence
net worth has averaged at 160 million
dollars i'm sorry for like she's the
victim right now guys we need to
understand that she's the victim in this
and we all need to feel sorry for her
her and megan merkel yeah they're the
real victims right now dreams are dr
carlson net worth 30 million dollars
yeah she's worth what was like just
five times yeah well it was all five so
160 yeah more than five times senator
carlson's net worth this is what happens
this is
man
people who are extremely powerful and
wealthy but it's it's the hunger games
it's capital city
which she actually was the main actress
there you go yeah it's ironic isn't it
that she in real life represents the
snooty people drinking ipac to vomit and
keep eating while poor people actually
suffer and there and and the funny thing
about the hunger games the movies i
don't know if it's the same thing in the
books the people in the capital are
oblivious to the suffering of the people
outside for the most part and they're
all weird-looking
oh yeah yeah they're all kind of like
blue hair
blue hair they're all shaved heads
slightly androgynous and
bizarre and uncomfortable and
she so so the problem is you get someone
like jennifer lawrence and one of the
quotes she has i don't know if it's in
the newsweek article but she said uh
here we go quote it breaks my heart
because america had the choice between a
woman and a dangerous dangerous jar of
mayonnaise and she said and they were
like well we can't have a woman let's go
with the jar of mayonnaise i don't want
to disparage my family but i know that a
lot of people are in a similar position
with their families how could you raise
a daughter from birth and believe she
doesn't deserve equality how that is not
why donald trump won i would say the big
reason
was a choice between donald trump and
hillary clinton is that i don't know
hillary clinton uh was the clinton
foundation was receiving money from
foreign governments while she was
secretary of state that the the obama
administration got us entangled in a
bunch of wars that hillary clinton said
we came we saw he died
yeah give me that against donald trump
you know what i still didn't vote for
him but then you give me joe biden and
you give me four years of what donald
trump was trying to do and i was like
okay all right
as if
the big issue for me
is that hillary clinton is a woman no
it's that she's a psychopathic she's a
sociopathic murderer
also what they did to bernie sanders was
unconscionable bernie was winning that
election he had all the energy and then
the clinton i don't know what
the dnc basically yeah that was under
donna brazil and if you remember donna
brazile actually was even giving hillary
clinton the questions ahead of time
before the presidential nomination
debates right and she was caught doing
this and she profited massively off of
this she gave hillary the questions when
she fought for the debate debate bernie
that's exactly because he didn't have
the questions that's insane if you know
that
this is the mentality
that we're up against her vote
is equal to yours daniel so when you
vote and she votes
she's like you just want to vote for
mayonnaise and you're like i have very
serious concerns about how people will
live when there's no energy
you're you hate women you're a racist
this is the new thing you're xenophobe
you know when you don't think exactly
like them they want a name called we saw
this from the president himself you know
the i call him the selected not elected
president of the united states but
you saw this where that's exactly what
he did he's gone now to name calling
and telling all of us you know first it
was we're deplorables now we're
extremists just because we care about
our nation and we are you know god
fearing america loving individual
patriots and now all of a sudden we're
labeled as extremists as a result of it
you know we don't think like you we
don't act like you we don't behave like
you therefore you are a racist or a
xenophobe or an extremist you know this
is really where the left has gone and
meanwhile the rest of us who are sitting
as part of maga or sitting as part of
the america first agenda we're just
simply saying well no
we just care about getting back to
constitutionality freedoms liberties the
rights for individuals the rights for
individual states the ability for people
to make their own decisions for the
protection of our children the you know
betterment of all of america getting
back to american exceptionalism no no
you're an extremist jennifer lawrence
cares so deeply about women's issues
that she stood next to harvey weinstein
probably did unspeakable things to him
to get ahead in her career and to get
the leading roles that she did as a 16
year old um and and watched millions
dozens of women get abused by harvey
weinstein
and but but you know what she cares very
very deeply what is it about women's
issues is her relationship with that guy
is that is that was that was that a big
story that's known absolutely yeah
absolutely i always love how they say we
care so much about women's rights but at
the same time they won't protect or even
try and prevent women's sports from
being taken as a b or a c or a d role
for biologically born men what was the
one winter's bone to uh the the one that
was awful with bradley cooper where
uh gosh the silver linings playbook
she's got a long history with harvey
weinstein and you did not get a leading
role as a lady in a harvey weinstein
film unless
you did the things that harvey weinstein
wanted you to do the article from
newsweek did you get eight hours ago
jennifer lawrence addresses rumors she
effed that's harvey weinstein that's
that's the same interview she did in the
in the interview with vogue she said it
was it's not true i'm sure she's no of
course not how that's not true of course
she's going to say it's not true you
know what is she going to come out and
say it's truthful well the only reason
people are saying is what i hate women i
think about exactly rights and black
rights and trans rights i think of like
human rights like it's we're not we
shouldn't be arguing about who gets the
better bedroom in the slave quarters it
should be about let's not be slaves
people it doesn't matter who you are
that's a great line that was great
that's a very good line
yeah i just i i am sick and tired of of
people glomming on to whatever they
think their unique qualifier is that
makes them a victim when they are the
most privileged
who in the world has more privilege than
jennifer lawrence if we lined up all
330 million americans in privileged
order where do you think jennifer
lawrence ranks does she rank i mean
you're definitely higher than i am but
60 million dollars but i mean think
about this idea of
what the left has gone to and it's the
same with meghan markle who gave another
interview yesterday about how hard her
life is the little princess right this
nonsense that we're always victims
because victimhood is very very sellable
to correct you i think she's a duchess
that's just but i mean what point at
what point you've won an oscar and
you're worth 160 million dollars
seriously at what point can you just
shut the hell up and say you know what
my life's been great but look oh yeah
this happens all the time though i mean
look at your actual
deal look you got athletes and you've
got people who have who've gone to the
ranks of political elites who want to
talk about how there's this systemic
racism that exists and there's this you
know glass ceiling
wait a second you're one of the leading
figures whether it's in politics or
whether it's in you know celebrity you
know status
how did that glass ceiling impact you
how how did that systemic racism prevent
you from becoming the vice president of
the united states or how did that
prevent you from becoming one of the
wealthiest talk show hosts in the world
or one of the wealthiest you know
basketball players but yet you want to
talk about how you're so disenfranchised
because the real victims in society
don't have a voice and it is the job of
a justice society to elevate those
people like what i was just saying about
electricity the the most abused people
in the green blackouts are going to be
people who are voiceless and powerless
and no one will stand up for them the
most abused people clearly are
celebrities worth
ten figures
nine
yeah yeah and joe biden ask him he'll
always tell you how hard his life was he
and eighty percent of his friends all
have cancer right he'll tell you guys
wraps up her day of work where she's
pretending to be somebody else granted
she's good at it good for her
she wraps up her day at work and then
probably hangs out in an infinity pool
with like rare imported escargot other
nonsense like
160 million dollar net worth it's good
it's like in that iron iron man 2 when
justin hammer the bad guy is eating the
the dessert and he's like it's italian i
have it imported every day or whatever
it's like okay well that sounds like
nancy pelosi when she was talking about
you know how disenfranchised she was
while she sat in front of what was it
like 30 dollar pints of ice cream behind
her 30 000.
i know everyone's suffering but i've got
30 ice cream in my freezer i will say
this i've had that ice cream once in my
life and it is really
really
really good but it is like 15 for a
little tiny thing it was remarkably good
but who i i can't afford it i can't
afford it on the regular and she opened
up her drawer by the way her sub-zero
was twenty thousand dollars and she had
two side by side and she opened up her
freezer drawer and she had probably
about
two hundred dollars worth of ice cream
in her in her twenty-five hours i'm sure
if you'd open up the main one it would
have been nothing but like vodka because
we all know that she's like perpetually
drunk it's it's fascinating to me
that there are uh
joe biden the democrats come out and
they're like republicans are just mad
the irs agents are going to go after
billionaires it's like dude 87 000
agents aren't needed to go after
like 500 billion yes around 479 or so
and if you're gonna go after
millionaires i think there's like 30 000
or something like that right yeah you
still don't need that many irs agents
one irs agent can handle multiple people
but again though i go back to the idea
which is that okay if you're there to
audit me i understand if you're trying
to say all right i need calculators and
ink cartridges and things like that but
why do i need six hundred thousand
dollars in small calorie ammunition why
do i need a roles and responsibility
that says i need to be able to issue
deadly force i need to go ahead and be
able to detain search warrants etc this
is deep state police force being gone
and i'll tell you something the average
american is not coming to me and my
constituents by the way are not coming
to me and saying hey you know what we
really need
we need 87 000 more irs agents you know
what they're saying we need to secure
our borders we need to get our energy
prices under control i need to make sure
that i am protecting my children in the
schools i need to make sure that our
economy and our inflation gets under
control
the everyday american
wants affordability and safety they
don't care about getting 87 000 irs
agents and this just shows the tone
death you know self-vilifying you know
effect of of the left and the liberals
that are basically saying no no no you
don't understand in 20 to 30 years this
is going to benefit you
the the irs criminal uh investigative
service i think it's something like that
it's been around for like 100 years
and and but but i think it's important
to point out
a lot of people made it seem like the
buying the bullets was a rare or new
thing that happens all the time and
that's something you all need to pay
attention to
they don't need those bullets for
billionaires
they're not going to jeff bezos house
with guns
they're going after now to be fair drug
dealers but they're going after people
who uh there was a in one of the
training sessions they did it was a a
guy who owned a landscaping business who
didn't report a lawn mower or something
like that
in that you know that video where
they're like they walk up to a guy and
they'll have the guns they're doing the
training they're going up to a small
business owner they're not practicing
going after cartels or anything they've
also learned that it's easier to force
you to comply at the end of a barrel
than it is from the end of an ink pen
and that's what we all need to be
concerned here and i'll tell you
something i mean going back
i i think in 1913 it was probably one of
the worst years for our constitution
because one we had the 16th amendment
which was federal income taxes and the
17th amendment which actually you know
stopped our u.s senators from actually
being elected by our state legislators
which actually controlled federal
overgrowth in the violation of our 10th
amendment but you know i'm one of those
guys that why should i be taxed on the
the hard work that i've you know earned
or the investments why couldn't be on
consumer and fair tax why can't we go to
something like this which actually makes
sense for every individual but not only
this why can't we reduce federal
government you know when it comes to the
irs or the atf or the doe or any of
these and that's department of education
by the way not energy but my whole point
is you can reduce energy
but but my whole point is federal
overgrowth
and the weaponization
of these departments and agencies
will be the death of america the 87 000
agents are going to do so much damage to
the daily commerce that we do as a
country uh it is not strange and venmo
was was very convenient for just getting
rid of like checks and paper and cash
but it was not hard to to bring you know
x number head of cattle and swap forty
thousand dollars and i'll keep that 40
grand in my venmo because i know
tomorrow i'm gonna do it on so and and i
don't really have the 40 000 i'm holding
it for a little while until i get the
cows back from auction and then the
venmo but if i have irs agents they're
gonna be like what was this forty
thousand dollar and that's exactly what
i was doing six hundred dollars what's
this forty that what's this four
thousand dollars you have on venmo well
it wasn't really a profit it was a tim
it was a transaction that was taking two
weeks and it's going to disappear it
doesn't matter where your taxes they
they tried implementing that policy or
that that law about tracking 600 dollar
transactions or more
yeah they're not going after
billionaires dude correct well we
already know that 75
of last year's audits were people that
was making less than 100 a year
so the idea that they're getting these
eighty seven thousand you know irs
agents
it it's it baffles my mind when i think
about the fact of what that costs and
why we're not allocating that money to
things like securing our borders or
increasing our law enforcement so we can
get increased criminality under control
or the fact that we're 12 to 15 000
recruitment short for our armed services
why aren't we looking at things that
actually matter to the everyday american
and the reason why
because the government wants to steal
every every penny they have out of your
pocket i think they it's a con
it's a slow motion demolition i mean
they're just this is the the military
for instance the recruitment who wants
to join a woke military no one does
they're worried about pronouns crt
inclusiveness diversity instead of the
things they need to be worried about
which is increased lethality readiness
and preparedness you know that's the
things that i focused on when i was in
the military yeah but if you're one of
these people who like that woman from
the guardian article who's like i would
never survive she's the kind of person
running the military these days thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there is a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there
you